from screenwriter and actor tom hanks
the legendary star
from films such as inferno the circle
extremely loud and incredibly close and
larry crown he's done some other films
too comes greyhound
i'm excited to check this trailer out
maybe we'll get the true story of mr
rogers 80 confirmed kills
which are true
[Music]
this comes out on your birthday yeah
that's what i wanted
dear lord let your holy angel be with me
all it sounds so your hands i commend
myself my body
and soul amen
[Music]
man of god
[Music]
wow
congratulations on your command
elizabeth's shoe
looks like it will always be looking for
you
even if i'm a thousand miles away
[Applause]
[Music]
here escort to greyhound
hey it's a big year for steve graham
[Applause]
he is the captain now
[Music]
we've lost seven chips
oh that looks nightmarish
whatever you did yesterday got us today
it's not enough
come on nearly enough
this is crazy
sir
tonight
[Music]
dwayne johnson awesome
i mean not real life but for a movie
awesome
yeah that looks cool thomas is gonna
kill him man
you know tom hanks in a world war ii
or you know period drama anytime he's
leading one of those i'm excited for it
i know there's going to be countless
captain phillips jokes now
a lot of i am the captain now because
this is like the first submarine
he's manning according from what i got
from the trailer as a character what i
really think is neat about it is he he
wrote the screenplay for it from what
we're getting about the
character from the teasers we got it
looks like it's a guy who has
a lot of doubts towards what he can pull
off his leadership like this is
the first time he's doing this now he's
in this insane battle like him praying
to god and then
when he's on the phone he's like this is
my first time there's this layer that
tom hanks can bring
where he's someone who's trying to find
the leadership confidence and strength
amidst all the self-doubt so i think for
a character portrayal and the fact that
he wrote it i imagine he wrote himself
probably a really rich character
to go off of here the battle sequences
look cool you don't really see
that many films especially with like war
movies that deal a lot with
naval battles at least hasn't been one
that's like a a big
hit in a while a lot of it does look
great like the night time sequences look
very intense the atmosphere and mood of
it feels very haunting
there's some questionable cgi here and
there
it's one of those cases where you're
like i wish it could have gone only
practical the entire time because there
are times where it's very evident that
it's cgi
for a movie like this as long as i get
the mood and the tone down right
you can be pulled into the immediacy of
the event i feel like you can really
look past a lot of that because unlike
other films like what was that roland
emmerich one that that just came out
that did not do well no midway midway
yeah like films like
midway where the cgi is like extremely
distracting
people where it's like a disaster movie
scale cgi
yeah and the tone of that just didn't
look very appealing and felt generic
this at least
still feels like incredibly intense
yeah it does liken you back to you know
the films that he's done in the past
like captain phillips
likes saving private ryan maybe they
don't feel as grungy and dirty and messy
in terms of its camera movement
but yeah you still feel the harrowing
effects of being in this
really scary out in the middle of
nowhere war battle
i i think this actually looks really
awesome yeah i do too i mean this seems
to me
the vibe i got off this trailer was like
it was somehow crashing together
the amount of you know crushing action
that you might see in a
in a michael bay style war movie not
that this is anything like
pearl harbor but you know the action did
look pretty spectacular but also on the
flip side it did look like a pretty
intense
character story when you're in a
submarine scenario or on a ship of any
kind there's some kind of claustrophobia
that sets in there and yeah this looks
like
a very personal movie but also a very
physical and very immediate and very
harrowing movie in a lot of ways and
that's
kind of to me what makes sense of the
summer like the right and the smack
middle of summer release date there
because it does look like it has enough
we're
giving it our all you know desperate
heroism type of action
you know that's got you know probably a
good amount of sacrifice but with uplift
and yeah you know tom
hanks playing a guy who is obviously of
the rank to be able to lead
doing it for the first time you know it
puts him in a more relatable place for
us
and yeah i mean tom hanks has that every
man quality and so to see him you know
kind of transcend that as this character
i think will be a nice thing and yeah i
mean this looks as much of a film as it
does you know a harrowing
physical you know yeah naval battle
movie and what i'm hoping
is that yeah we can get some great
submarine type sequences because like
hunt for red october has been on tv a
whole bunch lately that's a pretty great
movie too just you know that's coming
back to my mind while i was watching
this and some of those yeah more uh
submerged you know the red light and all
that stuff that moment with the radar
yeah that you uh were really chilled by
like yeah there's a lot that looks very
uh gripping about this in multiple
directions well i with that radar what
really stood out to me
that it clicked in the trailer this
director seems like he
and i'm sure working with tom hanks as a
screenwriter looks like they're really
capturing this only from our protagonist
perspective we know they're going up
against like the germans it doesn't look
like they're cutting to see
them and what they're doing it is that
intense scary
situation of you're trying to figure out
where the attacks are gonna be coming
from but you're never
gonna relieve the audience or showcase
what our enemies are doing
from their perspective so the whole time
it's like all you gotta work off of are
there people
in the planes there are people in these
other ships
there's all these mysterious bodies in
in what we're seeing in the radar sonar
that idea of only seeing from that
perspective of our characters
always makes it that much scarier like
having a bit of a horror tone to it
i think is a really smart idea for
something like this because war is
terrifying
war is terrifying when you deal with
perspective and tone and this
capacity i think that's the best
approach you can take with it and shout
out to stephen graham i first saw him in
the movie snatch he's worked a ton since
he had a lot of praise in the irishman i
still feel like he was overlooked
despite the praise that he received for
it
guy is amazing at accents i don't know
if he's like british or i think he's
british
british or irish one of the two i'm so
glad he got to be showcased a lot in
this trailer it's like this movie has a
traditional setup like him
and his wife elizabeth chu wanting to go
back home to her be safe that felt
a little generic but it's not about that
that's something to give us to latch on
to with this character you know so that
we could go home and see his wife and
now i'm curious to see because tom hanks
i know he just is coming off of an oscar
nomination for his work as mr rogers in
a beautiful day in the neighborhood he's
still an actor who
often gets gypped for a lot of
amazing captain phillips being one of
them he often is snub so i'm curious to
see that you know it's a summer release
date will they still remember him for
when the oscar voting session comes
around for this or will he get nominated
for
screenwriting that would actually be
really neat it seems like the kind of
movie that they would
mainly look at his performance instead
of the script but who knows i'm excited
to see what he has in store because he's
a talented writer yeah he knows a good
script
he he knows a good script generally
speaking yes larry crown
yeah or the da vinci guys but guys what
did you think of this greyhound trailer
leave your thoughts down below do you
think tom hanks has an oscar nomination
in sight
comment below subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell get
notified whenever we got a new youtube
video up and last but not least
derek mitchell i owe you a poem buddy
here we go his name is derek
never generic at times hysteric most
certainly
barbaric was once a driver for the
company uber or was it lyft
i don't remember regardless one of our
longest patreon members
he knows how to build computers can
probably beat me in first person
shooters
he'll tip immensely when dining at the
restaurant hooters
ladies look out no he's not a serial
killer but he's climbed many pillars off
comes the gloves and now he has a job
that he
loves now let's raise a glass and toast
to say 2020 will be a better year than
most
and thanks for putting up for all the
stupid roasts love you buddy
and somehow this links to the trailer we
watched
man those kids